the hate you give is a young adult novel
published by Angie Thomas just in
February 2017 - George and Marty and Rob
can you tell us a bit about this New
York time is 50 week bestseller and how
it came to be developed into a film on
the screen yeah he always wants to talk
but I will take this one ah we both read
the book our company George a nice
company and Marty's company in February
2016 and we you know we both have a deal
at Fox 2000 so at the same time we
brought the book in and Elizabeth Gabler
and Aaron siminoff loved the book
immediately like we did and it was
interesting because about I think it was
November of 2016 we read a draft an
early draft by Audrey Wells who
unfortunately everybody knows if hasn't
heard already passed away last week
right when the movie was coming out so
kind of dealing with that but she did a
fantastic job got it - right where we
wanted - and then the book came out the
following year in February and it's shot
to number one in a state of number one
for seven weeks so at that time like as
a producer you're like okay we're gonna
make this movie like the hell is the the
point where you know you're gonna go and
put this thing together and get going
that's fantastic and George wouldn't you
come on board yeah that was around the
same time I mean I think I read it in
January 2016
so I was actually working on a TV show
when it came to me and I was reading the
book at night and I was blown away in
the first 30 pages because it was just
about the ideal identification
identifying who you are this young girl
through two worlds and I was able to
identify that with myself and I felt
like I haven't seen a film with that so
I immediately got on a phone with Angie
and talked about themes talked about
story characters just something really
quickly and little did I know that a
mandala was reading the book as well
over at UTA and it wasn't even published
at the time so that's how I sort of came
to me at that time as you think about so
that that synergy talked about casting
so mandalas reading the book you're
thinking about casting it's coming
together an incredible team brought to
this this story how that process but
that was a great process because what I
met her
came in I was familiar with her work but
I never I never met her before so she
came to my office and it was just great
we just she started telling me a little
bit about her experience living in
Englewood and go into a white private
school I was really taken away how she
said that a lot of her friends she would
tell them when they come over to the
house he would give them a different
direction
safer direction where they could see so
I think it's like don't go down Crenshaw
something you know something so I love
that idea so I was listening to all
these things she was saying because I'm
in my 40s she's at that right age so I
was taking all these things and how
music are different in the different
worlds and how her vocabulary be
different so I was just incorporated
that all in my prep so when I saw her I
was like oh she's the one I think she
has the ability to listen and be in the
moment and being the scenes and that's
what I was attracted to the most you
know and there are other bridges in
terms of the story and generations and
bringing in mAb and Lisa so talk about
the casting of Ruslan and Regina
well that was great because I remember
Regina who she auditioned for me on
another movie a long time ago she blew
me away we had like this didn't get it
so far away said no so always remember
that okay so we had a great chance to to
work right away and Russell I just
remember Russell we were actually at
Four Seasons buffet on one Sunday he was
with his family I was with my family
that does pay off and that pays off the
fourth season buffet you know is
expensive is expensive it was worth it
because I got a chance to talk to
Russell and I saw him we're also been
doing it for a long time and he's
amazing so I'm a fan of his work so when
I saw this short film that he did and I
was blown away and I just talked to him
we met and then when he did this
monologue that was amazing it's just you
know I always just wanted to work with
him he's just he's just a great actor so
that's great what brought you to this
the book first and then the project and
and what it portraying this character
mean for you in this day and age yeah so
I first found out about this project and
because of the incredible book by Angie
Thomas and at that point it was as
George said unpublished you know there
were so typos in it it didn't even have
it wasn't even distributed yet it was
packaged it wasn't finished but the
material itself was just so
authentically beautiful to me in a way
that I felt like I hadn't necessarily
seen black characters postulated in in
media before and so that really spoke to
me I was able to relate to a lot of
stars experiences on a very personal
basis there were a lot of like weird
eerie parallels between my life and hers
and that was powerful just to unpack
certain things like the experience of
code-switching understanding that you
might shift how you present yourself
depending on the space that you're
entering in order to be less alienated
or to be more accepted the experience of
having friends who don't understand your
perspective and so you're kind of
shielding and hiding aspects of your
life from them because you know they
don't have that understanding those are
things that I could relate to and we're
so powerful to see explored within the
story and then stars voice was also just
you know as George said so fresh and
authentic and special and I felt like I
knew her just by reading and I felt like
you know I didn't like you know people
ask me sometimes like when you when you
read the book did you imagine yourself
as star like no that would be so bizarre
but I definitely felt like she was
someone that I knew but I hadn't seen
put in a piece of media like that before
Russell and MAV so really guiding us
through the experience through just the
story and presence of black man we don't
often see in in film and the role of
dieting father what drew you to the
story and what were you really really
intent on making sure it came through in
this character well in a word nuanced
you know you don't see these type of
characters on screen black man that is
strong that is full of integrity present
for his family a lover and has a sense
of tenderness you know about him and I
wanted to you know make sure that I
explored you know all of that Angie
wrote that was present in math
the one thing that really grabbed me
when I first read the script was the
first scene you know just that that
scene where a father is sitting at the
head of his table with his son and his
daughter sons and daughter and his wife
all together around a table was a
wonderful image for me you know a very
impactful image and I said to myself
that if this this scene stays in the
film I really felt that we have
something and I knew that for me that I
would want to be a part of that the you
know so again piggyback on what a
mandala said when you saw within when
you once you read the script you read
the book you anticipating more and feel
like we're part of more so a movement in
a sense and I wanted to offer up my
talent to be a part of that and so when
you can get in collaborate with with
talented artists such as we've have it's
a it's a joy and it's it's a rare
occurrence and so I feel like we've done
something special if for no other reason
that we had an opportunity to come
together as a family and create what I
feel as a dynamic piece of work
Lisa Carter Regina Hall so really a
bridge character in many ways someone
who's been out and those stars
experience but also in the community can
you tell us about you know your approach
to Lisa and approach this character in
this story a lot of people don't know
this but I had been imprisoned for about
four years one more thing that we didn't
know about Rajesh yeah no I have not but
I will say that when I read the book I
just I thoroughly enjoyed the book and I
just loved the lens that you know when
when I spoke to George that he wanted to
tell the story I think a manless
fantastic and it was great for me to
just be able to you know be able to play
the kind of women I've seen in my life
so much you know my mom my daddy was
present for anybody about to play a
violin like Oh another black Grover no
daddy but my daddy is dead that is true
don't laugh my father passed away but he
was a pretty incredible dad and so to be
able to see a father in the story to see
the dynamic of a mother and father who
are trying to raise kids I actually did
go to Catholic school myself and I grew
up in Washington so just understanding
the world of going you know where you
live and going to private schools so
they just there were a lot of dynamics
that were familiar and exciting and and
then it was a timely story you know I've
watched that so many times on the news
myself I've been one of the people where
I look at the news and I go oh that sad
and then I kind of go on throughout my
day and like this story stayed with me
and so I think when something resonates
so it resonates with you you're able to
start making decisions that can create
change and this movie kind of made me
compelled to do that what was most
challenging about bringing this project
to life and from the book through to
today it's interesting because every
time George talks about the material I
get excited all over again because I
love the energy in which he describes
the things that he does in the intensity
with which he he takes his job as a
producer I mean I think we can both say
you need half the battle is selling a
studio into wanting to do the project we
were very fortunate to have a great book
that had sold for a lot of money with a
wonderful actress and a wonderful writer
attached but we still had to convince a
studio to spend the money and I mean
just getting the the truth was getting
George on the phone with Elizabeth gable
who
is the studio executive in charge of
skin the movie done was the hardest part
of the project and once we did George's
passion made it something that it was
impossible for her to say no to in this
environment in current conversations
around identity police brutality
community and the future of America that
we see playing out in our streets and
our televisions and our halls of power
you know how do you hope that hate you
give will will fit into that
conversation how do you think it how do
you hope it will impact where we are and
where we had we keep getting asked this
a really great question which is what is
the role of the filmmaker within social
movements and I feel like you know they
hate you give is not necessarily
pointing towards one action piece or one
particular movement that we are supposed
to do as a community but rather kind of
have that that relationship with
activism that is so symbiotic and both
components are equally as important it's
supposed to be a space for us to
understand these events in a way that's
really human and grounded especially
amidst times that are really chaotic and
divisive and sometimes when we are
pushing for change we don't necessarily
give ourselves the time to sit down and
feel and recognize what it is we're
fighting for and what it is we're going
through and so I think that you know
this this one of my favorite parts in
the movie is when star says to Haley
Haley says oh are you calling me racists
and she says no I just asked you a
question and I feel like this film asked
question and and our intention was to
offer the space to allow people the time
and room to feel these events to
empathize with them to process
especially if it's something they've
experienced personally or are even
peripherally you know affected by and to
kind of ground us in the middle of
pushing forward and getting tired
because the world is looking really
scary
the time in the space to be human yeah
thank you for that ladies and gentlemen
I hate you go